vous avez plusieurs centaines voire même
là en parlant milliers d'individus dans
le lit presque 50 cm de diamètre c'est
la taille du nid de frelons repéré sur
une propriété de jouars pontchartrain
il nécessite une intervention rapide on
va injecter directement la poutre qui
est compressé dans le monde au le pirate
dans le petit trou qui est ici donc l
entrée du nid le produit utilisé le
pyrèthre végétal insecticides pleurer
maintenant dans la nature il avant les
occupants momentanément agressif je mets
des lunettes
l'ag des projections de venin
directement dans les yeux voyez sur la
visière donc là surtout on laisse le nid
en place avec l'insecticide pendant 72
heures et s'il doit y avoir un retrait
ne se fera uniquement après 72 heures de
traitement dans un nid de cette taille
là on a plusieurs milliers d'individus
savoir car ni qui n'est pas traitée
générer entre 12 et 14 mille frelon est
à peu près 6 à 800 fondatrice pour
l'année prochaine à la chance au niveau
de la région ile-de-france d'avoir un
organisme qui s'appelle la fredon et qui
a mis en place un protocole
d'intervention qui repose entre autres
de laisser les mis en place la société
dgf a reçu pendant l'été entre 80 à 120
demandes par jour
le confinement a permis à certains ni de
proliférer en toute tranquillité final
est assez particulière pour plusieurs
facteurs déjà on a eu un hiver qui était
très propice au développement des
fondatrices qu un hiver qui était très
doux avec un printemps qui a suivi avec
des températures qui ont été régulières
c'est une saison un petit peu différent
des autres parce qu'effectivement on
augmenter notre volume d'interventions
qu'on a multiplié quasiment par deux et
demi par rapport à la saison dernière
il reste encore un mois avant la fin de
la saison des guettes les nids de
frelons peuvent persister plus longtemps
s'ils n'ont pas été traitées d'ici là